in molti mi chiedono perché vivo ancora
in sicilia a generare uno strano effetto
non è solo il fatto che un bambino
siciliano abbia deciso di votare la
propria vita al jazz ma anche il fatto
che questo bambino diventato poi il
ragazzo abbia deciso di viverci in
sicilia per molti insomma questi aspetti
rappresentano l'eccezione ma oggi qui
con voi vorrei condividere tre validi
motivi
affinché quella che è solo un'eccezione
possa diventare una regola una vera e
propria regola di vita
il primo motivo per restare è
semplicissimo per mantenere la propria
identità sono tantissimi giovani che
sono costretti a emigrare per motivi
lavorativi
ovviamente non mi riferisco a coloro i
quali lo fanno per libera scelta per
gusto personale per ambizione parlo di
chi si sente obbligato a farlo per paura
di non riuscire a realizzarsi certo
viaggiare e meraviglioso conoscere nuovi
luoghi 9 culture non vede ma chi lo fa
perché crede di non avere alternative a
rischia di perdere le proprie radici
la propria identità e io credo
fermamente che questi due aspetti siano
una ricchezza inestimabile su cui
costruire la propria personalità e da
cui partire per creare qualcosa di nuovo
ed eccezionale
si dice sempre che il jazz sia nato
dall'incontro di più culture quello che
non si dice e che insieme ad africani ed
ebrei sia stata proprio la tradizione
bandistica siciliana a far nascere
questo genere musicale
e allora io proprio in onore in memoria
di queste radici che fortunatamente non
ci sono perse voglio suonare per voi una
mia composizione che si intitola la
banda
pallone
caro
no
voleva
si no
no
all
con
c'è un altro motivo per cui un giovane
dovrebbe pensare di restare nella
propria terra d'origine per cambiare ciò
che lo circonda così tante persone
parlano di andare via
emigrare scappare che spesso vediamo chi
rimane come uno sconfitto
e chi invece va via come chi ce l'ha
fatta
io ovviamente non sono d'accordo
conoscere il mondo può contribuire a
migliorare noi stessi ad ampliare i
nostri orizzonti ma può anche servirci
per migliorare il contesto da cui
proveniamo in cui viviamo
io per esempio viaggio moltissimo ma poi
sento l'esigenza di fare base in sicilia
perché ho deciso di coinvolgere nel mio
progetto di vita anche la mia comunità
e c'è una cosa che mi rende
particolarmente orgoglioso il jazz
festival della mia città natale vittoria
siamo ormai arrivati alla settima
edizione è il livello e internazionale e
vi assicuro che da direttore artistico
non potrei essere più fiero di come il
jazz si è diventato ormai una ricchezza
di tutti un genere di nicchia che piano
piano a pressione sempre più persone
ed è proprio appunto con l'invito a
migliorare il contesto che ci circonda
che voglio suonare per voi un'altra mia
composizione che ha proprio questo
spirito che ho scritto ispirandomi a
questo concetto e il titolo è lì
creating
grazie
paola ceroni
c'è un altro motivo per cui provare a
restare necessario spesso chi vorrebbe
restare non lo fa perché teme di
sentirsi solo ha paura di non essere
supportata aiutato sostenuto io credo
che non cerchiamo abbastanza se facciamo
le cose veramente bene prima o poi ci
imbatteremo in qualcuno che è disposto a
mettersi in gioco al nostro fianco ad
aiutarci a sostenerci forse dovremmo
provare a cercare meglio vicino a noi
piuttosto che partire per posti lontani
a tal proposito credo che a volte basti
dare un buon esempio per ricevere delle
risposte sorprendenti
insomma per concludere credo che restare
e non accontentarsi possano benissimo
andare d'accordo e quindi con la
speranza di festeggiare tanti successi
di chi ha avuto il coraggio di restare
di chi ha il coraggio di restare che vi
saluto con un'altra mia composizione che
si intitola la festa
non va bene